[Music]
everyone is gifted the question is
at what stress is actually the internal
force that pushes
out against pressure two words i
actually wish we could just take them
out
are can't and shame
and there she is hi hiya how are you
doing
great to see you great to have you on so
ladies and gentlemen this is nancy
gaines who's a uh
it's hard to sum up your story you've
done so many pins
uh what a wild journey you've been on so
she's a former ceo
of a of a money management company she's
a harvard trained
negotiator and mediator uh she
is on his mission to have more
confidence in the world wants to donate
a million books of kids and she's the
author of a new book called tina
searches for her dreams that i've got
here
super exciting we're going to link that
in the description below for youtube
nancy welcome aboard so good to see you
great to be with you so i i mean there's
so many ways to take this conversation
but
the first thing that really struck me i
don't think i've had a children's
author book on before but the mission
the mission is so big of what you're
trying to do
when she sent me these books there's
three versions of the same book
and the difference is just the skin tone
so it's like the exact same book
the illustrations are are beautiful the
store is exactly the same just three
different
skin tones talk to us about
why i've never been shipped three
versions of the same book
so so take us behind the scenes of why
three different skin tones
oh thank you for asking that well the
entire book as you saw is very diverse
and we think it's very important for
kids and adults to be able to see
themselves in the books that they read
so and beyond that especially
in the lead right so that
being able to choose the tina with your
favorite skin tone or the skin tone that
speaks to you or that you just
want enables you to see yourself as the
lead
read through but again the whole book is
diverse
i know you're really passionate about
helping kids and adults
increase their confidence what are your
tips suggestions advice to help them do
that
well confidence really is the heartbeat
of the can-do attitude
so the more that we can instill
confidence in kids and bolster
the confidence in us as adults the more
we can accelerate
right into our goals and our dreams
and it basically starts with how are we
framing our wins
right so if you look at professional
baseball for example
for a pro ball player a 300 batting
average is like
wow great right but that means that
every time that player is up to bat
i mean overall seven ten of the times so
up to bat
they're striking out seven of them right
but what do they do we're focused on
those three times
getting on base and so we'll hopefully
get some home runs too but it's really
to get onto first base
then second then third then home
and it's it's also very much like the
way we start our lives as babies or when
we watch our babies
walk right one day baby just gets up
and takes one step it
falls but that baby doesn't think oh
that's it
i fell i'm done i can't do this
or then it gets up again and it's wobbly
it doesn't think oh i'm wobbly i'm on my
balance i don't know where i'm going
i'm down i'm done no it gets up it's
just
focused on its goal of walking
and then what do we do is as parents or
adults when we
watch these children right we cheer
that very first baby step
literal baby steps for cheering each one
right along the way
to the goal so i think that tells us a
lot about
how we need to really count those wins
celebrate those wins those baby steps
along the way
each one it's not just reaching the goal
and realizing the dream
so if we're not born with it right we're
born and we're just
yeah really not lower the place how does
that get
trained into us you're saying if you're
not born with it we are born
well if we're not born with the lack of
confidence right right right
we're like afraid of people's judgment
we're just going to fall all over the
place and we don't care
we're pooping in our diapers yes we
don't care
but then at some point it gets trained
into us to
worry about other people's opinions of
us or how we're seeing or how we show up
and
so where do you think that gets trained
into us from is there is there a certain
age or is there a certain process that
people go through because
at some point we become adults and we
all now become afraid of
oh my gosh who's going to see me you
know what am i wearing and how am i
appearing so
we go through this massive
transformation why does that happen
yes these self-conscious moments and
i think so much of it stems from what
you've latched on to i mean you're
changing the paradigm
of beliefs and these beliefs so many of
them are really like these
these scripts with really undermining
messages
that we then just start acting out and
we start getting self-conscious because
what we're hearing and what other people
are saying and
that's one of the really big benefits of
children's stories that can
deliver these clean messages so that
people start having compassion
for each other and not just pointing out
oh look what johnny did
look what you did and all of a sudden we
pull back from that that sense of
you know i don't even believe in shame
and that's what happens you start
feeling nervous or ashamed or as you
were saying looking at what everyone
else is
thinking and that's one of the things
about tina
she just shakes all that off she just
goes from thing to thing and
and shakes it out and and then as adults
you are
starting off with the confidence it's so
important to
really develop those extra levels of
confidence because then you can kind of
shake it off it's almost like you have
this extra armor that you don't have to
walk around with all the time
but if something comes at you you can
kind of bounce back at it
and one of those areas is helping
children
and actually adults too work on
having become really clear clean
decision makers
you know being able to discern and
decipher and decide
quickly i mean how many adults do you
know that really have
decision paralysis and teenagers really
talking about age groups teenagers can
really get confronted because
they're looking in the mirror they're
seeing every little thing they're
involved in all these changes in their
lives and they're
really fuzzed out and and concerned so
if we can really drill that down
early it bolsters you and it's not that
hard you can start young and you give
two choices this is one of those times
when open-ended questions don't work
keep it two really direct two choices
so for example do you want this cereal
or that cereal
the child will just kind of look and
they decide and then go with what
they've chosen
and you just do this all day long
because we make all these decisions for
our kids because we just
do it's easy we grab their outfit for
the day we grab
you know their coloring box or their
crayons whatever it is we just grab it
and give it to them
just take a moment and ask them let them
make that choice do you want the yellow
shirt
or the green shirt to us that's nothing
but to them it's a big decision
so you keep really developing that
neural network where they are strong
decision makers and it becomes quick
when my kids were
little i really liked animal crackers
because they actually liked them
and i would they all taste the same
they're just crackers but they have a
different shape so i would
pick them up and even when they were so
young that they didn't speak that well
i'd hold it at a distance
and say do you want the bear or the
monkey
and he would say god laugh right they
were so
kind like it was gonna make a big
difference this was a big choice
that they would choose and i would hand
it to them and they would just feel good
about it
and that one thing you can do it as an
adult as well if you find that
it's really hard to make decisions just
break down these little decisions you
make automatically during the day and
instead of just
doing these things presented to yourself
like a choice
the same way i was doing it with the
kids and you just develop a strong
neural network of making choices
i'm going to be honest if you gave me
the option between a monkey and a bear
and a
cracker i'd still take a second
yeah i'd probably go monkey i'm thinking
monkey i don't know
just um
i love it and so what what i love about
you know
the kids book is like there's so many
lessons even though it said this is a
pretty
easy book to get through right yes uh
and what's the age group that you're
thinking for this
group it's really three to seven
but what's interesting about tina's
searches for her dream which is what you
were just getting at there
is that the messages are actually
timeless
they actually serve adults as well as
they serve
little ones so for little ones you're
kind of grooving in
that way of thinking but adults it helps
to give the pivot
like for example that feeling stuck
i mean we all talk about that when you
just feel you've invested
so much into something how do i make the
pivot
you know i experienced that when i went
to law school was my mother's dream
wasn't my dream but she hadn't fulfilled
hers and so she figured oh good i have a
daughter who can do well in school
she'll fulfill my dream and i finished
but i made the pivot because i knew it
wasn't
right for me but what if i hadn't you
know you can just stay and keep doing
what's
wrong for you but it's not that you
don't pick up and learn there
aren't really it's not a mistake to have
taken a detour
it's only a mistake if you don't keep
going back onto your main road
because then from that detour you can
pick up so much experiences and you meet
friends and you
you learn you learn learn and grow grow
grow it's just not where you want to
stay
so tina makes that pivot and she doesn't
know she's really bad at all these
things
she doesn't just she kicks the ball in
the wrong direction she lands in the
water but she just keeps going
she keeps going and going doesn't stop
until she finds hers
and how do you get the confidence
speaking about confidence to
walk away from that kind of career i
mean you go to
become a lawyer you go to harvard it's
not like just whatever some law school
to then say no i'm gonna have the
confidence to live
my life instead of what my parents might
want for me
well the law school wasn't harvard but
the the
the mediation and the and the
negotiation was harvard
and you're right i still i still
remember
how i was shaking at the time i wanted
to make a pivot
and i actually told my grandfather
and thought he was going to say oh my
gosh how could you not be a lawyer
and he said oh that's fabulous because i
knew i knew i wanted to make a pivot to
finance and he said
that's great do it honey so i was lucky
that i had someone immediately
give me that like shot of adrenaline and
i would have done it anyway but i would
have had even more trepidation so when i
picked up the phone and said oh my
i'm dad something yeah but you're right
it's life life takes courage
life is you know life isn't easy
we would like to think life is easy it's
not and are we
living life to the fullest then
we're always going to be facing those
those challenges and fears
but if we recoil back then at the end
we're going to have so many regrets you
know people people at the end of life
often sit there literally days left
all the fears are gone all these fears
that they walked around with for their
whole lives are gone
and then they get flooded with you know
what
look what i could have done if i just
hadn't let the fear get in the way
not have no fear but not let that fear
be my stop
i mean i asked because there's so many
people in my audience who are
at that phase two right now where
they're they want to make a change
they want to do something else they know
and the thing that they're
that they went to school for or their
parents hoping to do is is not what
their heart is into
but they they lack the confidence and
the courage to
to take the steps to take the leap to
make the phone call to say i'm gonna do
this and so if this is dream that just
kind of
stays with them forever is
regret the thing that you advise people
to do to say hey like imagine yourself
when you're
150 years old or however long you end up
living and say you're going to regret
this if you don't take action
absolutely that's one of the really good
ones because
if you can live life with as few regrets
as possible
you're going to be happy you know years
ago a friend of mine
was writing a book and he asked me to
read the the draft and it was an
exercise in there and you had to
imagine you were gone you had already
died and you you're
looking at your headstone and what would
you want on that headstone
to make you feel you had a life that was
worth living to you
and he said it couldn't be oh i had kids
that i love can't be oh i married
someone that i love
it had to be something completely
separate from that and i really pondered
it and that's when i realized
oh no regrets
now you can't really live with no
regrets you're gonna go oh why didn't i
do this but
but as few as possible and that actually
changed my life he did me the he asked
me for the favor but it was the biggest
favor
for me when he asked me to do that so
that's
kind of my driving force what will i
regret
what won't i regret and we tend not to
regret what we try or do
we might go oh boy that wasn't going to
work i'm not going to do it that way
again
but we don't really regret because we've
tried it we regret what we
didn't try but we didn't give ourselves
a shot and that's why
back to the baby steps and
it doesn't matter so what so what if you
have
a little bump or a stumble okay
i stumbled i was out there i did it it's
that pat on your back again it's
counting the wind
the win is i tried not and then if you
make the next steps great and we want
some of those big wins too but
we need to count all our wins you know
so many times
at the end of the day especially you
know entrepreneurs you have lists and
lists of things you want to get done you
think
oh gosh i didn't get to all those no
have the list check it out did it did it
did it and whatever you didn't get to
sure put it to the next day
i love it well we got nina here in the
chat who's saying that she's feeling
very fearful
right now about taking the next step in
her life and i know
fear and also anxiety is something that
you
talk about a lot what advice would you
give to
nina and the nina's of the world to
embrace their inner tina
you know and make it happen well
it's anxiety it starts with
people not really understanding what
anxiety is we know what it feels like
we don't really know what it is a lot of
people think that anxiety is stress
to the max and and that makes it harder
for us to get our hands on it
when stress is actually good stress is
actually
of course that's good for us it's when
stress
collides with fear it combusts
into anxiety so when you feel
anxiety know there's a fear
so you have to find the fear and
sometimes they're pretty obvious like oh
i'm really afraid i'm gonna fall on my
face
look like an idiot or or i'm afraid i'm
not going to be as good as someone's
always doing
the comparison issue which again with
tina you can't compare yourself to all
the others in that class
right but whatever that fear sometimes
it's right on the surface but sometimes
we have to be that archaeologist
and really dig and dig into it until we
find it
and then the really hard part is when we
find it
we have to face it because if we just
leave it the fear is still there the
anxiety is still
combusting we have to face it and once
we face it
it does quell but then the layer right
under
that anxiety is pressure and so going
back to stress being good
stress is actually the internal force
that pushes out
against pressure there's a real balance
that when
our stress and pressure are working in
balance we're rolling
literally rolling it's when they get out
of balance i mean if you think about it
when you
when you go exit well you still go to
the gym but no if you're
exercising at home you're stressing your
muscles but what are you getting
stronger bones bigger muscles better
vascular system
when you stress by studying hard you're
stressing your brain but you're getting
brighter smarter greater capacity so if
you
think of stress almost like a like a
soccer ball or actually more like a
basketball
really filled with air and you bounce it
boom bounces right back right
we bounce back when our stress force
is full but the pressure can wear down
our stress
force and that's when we start feeling
stress because
we're actually screaming from the inside
we're diminishing our stress
force we're losing some of that steam
some of that
inner pressure so that's when you have
to focus on reducing pressure
and i always recommend make a whole list
you have to leave it by your nightstand
or some more table just keep going back
to it as more things come to you
and then separate out those pressures
that are somebody within your control
you have agency over from those that
they're really somewhat out of your
control the things you absolutely have
to do
in life and then look at those pressures
that you do have agency over
and decide are they really that
important to me can i reduce these can i
even let some of these go
so you take the pressure down and get
yourself back in balance
so the bottom line is when you're
feeling stress
find the pressure when you're feeling
anxiety
find the fear i like it this there's a
lot of distinctions in that in that
four-minute talk you just went on that
i'm gonna probably have to walk back
and watch again to really incorporate
because
other people aren't talking about that
so i appreciate you spending the time on
it
um you mentioned shame a little bit
earlier on
so in that circle where does shame fit
i actually think we're not supposed to
feel shame two words that i really don't
i actually wish we could just take them
out are can't
and shame i mean very few things we
can't do but
it's more i don't want to i would much
prefer people to say
i don't want to there's a real
empowerment in that it's harder to do if
someone says i want you to do something
oh i can't do it it just pops out of our
mouths but
that's a victim thing i can't i can't
we're putting i can't into our heads and
i really believe the more
we say i can and i
want or i don't want the more in our
center and the more empowered we are
and a lot of that goes back to again i
think what you're doing is just
so spectacular it's such a beautiful
mission
because the more people believe in
themselves
we're here for a purpose believe in
yourself you have a gift
like with tina to going back to the
story
the the purpose yeah
tina is all about her story is
everyone is gifted the question is
at what and it's
having the confidence and the courage to
go for it
without letting the fear of judgment and
doubt and disappointment
stop us and that sometimes we have to
let go
of what we think will make us happy in
order to really realize our dreams
and so how do you connect that to shame
then as well so
if you feel shame that is someone else's
voice that does not belong there
actually blaring at you when person
feels shame
it's not just like a little voice i
should do this i should do this which
again i think should
should means when you say i should means
do it
right if you're saying i should do it if
you say
but anyway with with shame
it's like a fall corn glaring at you and
it's someone else's belief it's someone
else's thought
that you've been taken in to say i don't
even deserve to almost be here
shame i wrote a poem in my
quote book that says shame is a dart
aimed at your heart
this one yes this is more for adults but
this is this is fantastic
yes things so shame is a dart aimed at
your heart
laced with the poison of self-loathing
with each piercing blow the prouder
brought low
crushed by the hammer of judgment's
cruel hammer
and that's what it is it's someone
else's judgment it's not yours i mean
that one could bring me to tears because
no shame you're great people are great
we're out there trying and doing this is
this is the more we let ourselves live
life the more we let ourselves try and
go
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
if we've done something that we then
want to adjust and pivot and if god
forbid we have hurt
someone else make it right
make a right so with fear
you have to face it with shame you have
to do what
you have to just kick that out and say
that kick it out it doesn't belong to me
it belongs
it belongs to you and i bet someone
would even be able to know who put that
shame thought
that they think if they do x y or z they
should feel shame
they're thinking that's why i went back
to the should the link is
the person's thinking if i did x y or z
or feel x y or z or m god forbid
x y or z i should feel shame
and again it gives me shake because the
answer to that is
no you are a beautiful soul
each one of us has these huge souls that
actually live in our bodies and we have
these
these incredible minds that function
through our brain
but these but our vast unlimited souls
and minds that can just
go and bring in from so many sources
can get caught trapped
captured by these by the physical
limitations
because of those scripts
those belief scripts or those shame
scripts or how
trauma and pain gets embedded in our
bodies
and encoded in our brains so one of the
ways
that i focus on helping people to get
out of that
break that get back into control of your
life
and control of your choices because our
lives are defined
by the choices we make is
is an acronym that is raps
reflect ask questions plan
small steps and the reflect is really to
put yourself in a state of awareness
however you can best do that and just
literally be aware of all those errant
thoughts
all of where you are what's happening in
your life
just purely a state of awareness and
then from that state of awareness
start asking questions what do i really
want my life to be
or more importantly feel like
in the future what habits really don't
serve me
they keep getting me in the same trap so
what habits would i really
like to let go of what happens habits
would i like to start
putting into my life all these what's
what do i want what do i want
from there why start asking why a lot of
people talk about how wise the real
motivator and that's because it really
is why do i want all those things i just
figured out
is it still because someone else has
that expectation for me
or is this my life it's we're only given
one ours so it's
mine it's yours it's your listeners it's
everyone out there what do
why do i want this and be sure it's what
you want for real and then you get to
the
planning which is the how
how am i going to get there how am i
going to get to the make the what's
a realized reality and
from that it's the plan in the long term
the shorter term all the way up to the
day plan
right which is i always suggest do your
day plan yesterday
so that when you wake up you have that
plan ready to go
and from that day plan then you keep
marking it out
going for it and i really believe the
acids small steps
my father always used to say especially
when i had a lot to do
he'd say if you have to eat an elephant
start with the tail and part of the
reason he said that is
you finish the tail and it's like yay
got this done
again it's it's counting your win got
this then the next then the next then
the next
so each bit and piece that you succeed
at finishing
is a success and do all those small
steps before you know it ah
done with the elephant i love it i love
it nancy
it's it's amazing how time flies when
you're having fun i could talk to you or
even just listen to you for hours
uh guys you need to go check out nina
searches for
for her dream there's three versions of
it different skin tones
we're gonna link that up in the
description below uh if you have
a three to seven year old or if you have
someone in your family who's three to
seven years old
nieces nephews uh friends
gifted to them and for the adults out
there we didn't really talk too much
about this one but
this is a this is a super great book as
well finding peace at the center of the
storm lots of little poems that you can
read
super short like one one per day just as
a daily kind of reset
we'll link that up down below as well
nancy appreciate the love
the energy your vibe your warmth
answering all of my questions it's been
amazing and and just super pumped for
these books to get out there
oh thank you so much have a fabulous day
all right take care if you want to see
the one-on-one i did with marie forleo
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there modern
entrepreneurship can be for everyone
all of us are immersed in a culture that
has taught
us that non-stop work is the most
valuable thing
the brain needs break